welcome back to the show it has been a
huge huge
political week so many things have taken
place and i know people are eager to
uh chat and tell me what they're
thinking of and what's going on and
let's do it via discord at
davidpakman.com
uh you can also join the discussion
happening on discord i think close to
i think we've got close to 10 000 people
on our discord which is
a perfect number let's first go
to uh let's go to jill
from burbank jill from burbank you're on
the air
what is going on
hi david good morning to you oh it's
morning over here
how are you pretty good how about
yourself
uh doing well how's it it's raining in
burbank
um so i was gonna ask you in regards to
the policy
what do you wanna see um you know now
the democrats have
the senate and the house yeah and the
presidency
yes uh what policies do you want to see
i really want to see
progressive um you know
the green new new deal like on the table
the beta what do you um
i mean listen jill it's such a long list
so first on day one
you know day one could mean the first
couple of weeks
joe biden needs to do everything he
promised to do via executive order that
he can do and reversing a lot of the
things that donald trump did
i think using the defense production act
to scale up vaccine
production is something i would i would
be very interested in
very quickly uh he and democrats in the
house and senate
should be able to should be able to get
a bigger stimulus done
uh having mitch mcconnell um out of
power is just
uh such a fantastic thing
um and then i want biden to get started
on the big things let's get started on
the public option let's get started on
the energy uh and climate proposal that
he did which is not the green new deal
but takes a lot from the green new deal
um let's do minimum wage i mean
it's such a long list it's all possible
now but now is when the work begins and
that's the thing
there's i saw a lot of people gloating
this is just the beginning
this is we we now have to actually get
something done and it's not going to be
as easy as many think but
the list is very long and it's exactly
the type of thing we should be thinking
of
right uh what what do you think uh the
student loan
is gonna get passed uh at all like uh
student loan forgiveness he says you
know i'm skeptical
i'm skeptical that it's going to get
passed and um
that that one i would love to see
something done on student loans it's a
huge priority
and be very economically stimulative to
redirect money
away from being interest paid to banks
to money people can spend at local
businesses but i i am i have a
skepticism that that gets done in the
next two years
and i feel like that's the problem with
you know biden and you know the
difference between trump and biden trump
you know says something he just goes and
writes whatever
and you know it's it's an executive
order yeah but that's right
let's not give trump too much credit
trump did nothing on health insurance
trump promised health insurance
he yeah it's not he's yeah i hate him
but
he you know he does that i i wish you
know that
no but i think the point is trump has
done nothing on many of the
it's not just that trump is odd he does
bad things but he does them
most of the stuff he promised he just
didn't even he just didn't even come
close to doing he just didn't do
anything on
i i totally agree with that yeah
you know just but like for example for
toilet and stuff he just when
he does nothing really what he wrote but
he
goes ahead and writes a writes an
executive order
but anyways in regards to the mega
people that's the last question
what's the best way to you know change
their heart i mean i from my experience
i think
showing how we used to be you know how
we used to
talk as a family friend um
is the best way but what do you think is
the best way to do it i don't think
that there is any what i call retail
strategy
arguing with individual trumpists
one-on-one
it's there's no way there's no way we
need
a wholesale strategy which includes
cultural change
educational change and it's a it's at
least a decade process unfortunately and
i know a lot of people want
just like what's the trick to convince
these three maggot people i know to
change their minds
it the the problem is just wait it's way
bigger than that unfortunately well
thank you so much uh david do you
do exactly what you're doing and we love
you thank you all right
jill from burbank very much appreciate
the call we are taking calls
uh via discord davidpakman.com
discord you may not have known this but
when you see me
sitting here on the show i am often
wearing shirts by a company called teddy
stratford i asked them to be a sponsor
because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt
in a specific way that makes your upper
body look a lot better it's just a much
nicer and more stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100 percent
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout